all right here he is general manager the
Pittsburgh Steelers joining us from his
home and Pittsburgh I assume it's in
Pittsburgh it's got to be somewhere near
Pittsburgh we're in Pittsburgh deal if
you don't to give us your address we
won't anybody showing up but what's what
what area of the town do you live in
they're gonna walk right now I was right
smack downtown it's so we've been
downtown for two years and it's been fun
enjoyable and just a different party
lights right now we were in Pittsburgh
downtown last summer and it's amazing
how much it's changed in just a fairly
short period of time the number of
restaurants that have opened the number
of hotels that have opened it's stunning
to me because when I worked in
Pittsburgh back in the early 90s at
night the town basically went into a
slumber on weekends nothing was going on
now it's very lively and very dynamic
much more than it was just a few years
ago but definitely more than it was in
the early 90s there's no question I mean
there's a lot of things going on there
with the PPG Center and Heinz Field and
PNC Park right across the right across
the wire all within walking distance the
cultural districts picked up you know
with that the Convention Center and some
of the restaurants and hotels of it
picking up around and obviously a little
bit of a hold of the world only come on
who continue it'll continue the good a
lot of good going on well you're a
Pittsburgh guy through and through I
grew up 60 miles away but you had a five
year detour in Miami with coach Shula
who passed yesterday first of all
condolences on that but give us that
first memory that comes to mind for you
when you think of your time is spent
working with coach Shula well you know
what Mike it was it was kind of a
surreal moment you know as a young scout
just coming off a bless toe position to
join the Dolphins and to be in the same
room with coach Shula was truly
intriguing surreal intimidating to a
certain extent it was real and I learned
so much from coach coach was always very
demanding but he wasn't as demanding on
a young scout like myself he was the man
denied you know a 20-year assistant
coach that he's known forever and you
know he wanted
when he wanted answers you had to
provide them and that's he didn't own he
didn't have too much for you but if he
provided them the better have evidence
back for you get challenged on your
thinking so I mean he made all of us
better and it's you know sometimes you
can stink back him you know you have to
pinch yourself a mirror lies how
fortunate you were to work for me I'm
like that it especially at a young age
like there was is there something
tangible that you learned from working
with him that you still use today yes I
mean I can remember it clean and today
we're talking about a player I don't
know which player was and and he just
made the comment well when you got red
paint painted on bread make sense and
you know and he lived that you know when
coaching the players that he had and he
got the most out of them when he had the
great honors they were around now when
he had you know the great passer and
Emilee know they were passing from them
I just always remembered that and we
still lose that today in our own needing
to know this is what this player is and
when we get him that's probably what how
we should move him and it's funny that
you say that because I'm sitting in a
barn that is painted red because we had
red paint so grow it works out very
perfectly you know I saw yesterday that
Dan Marino recalled meeting coach Shula
for the first time after he was drafted
but he never spoken to him before the
Dolphins picked him now that was because
of that slide that Dan Marino had in
1983 but back in those days would it
have been as unheard of for a coach to
have never spoken to a guy he drafted as
it would be today
Oh probably you know that's today we
have so much more interaction we know
they had combines I don't know if they
did interviews at the combine when Dan
come on I wasn't in scouting at that
point dance when Dan came out but I
don't think they did the actual
interviews like we doing today I don't
think we started black really until the
early 90s so that part was probably miss
so unless the coach went out to work
you're out they probably didn't have
that same interaction well it wasn't
that long ago that you were making your
picks in this year's draft and you
didn't have a first-round pick because
it became defensive back maker
Fitzpatrick during the 2019 season
Brandon being the Bill's general manager
was in the same boat he traded away his
first-round pick for receiver Stefon
Diggs and he told me that that he
basically had to restrain himself from
trading back into round one how hard was
it for you to not try to swing a deal to
get back into round one once the name
started flying on that first night of
the draft
well you know what like we knew we
didn't have the ammunition to do it and
we feel very comfortable and not having
a first-round pick in this draft
obviously because we had ninka but also
getting to sit back and watch how this
would unfold because when we all went
into this we had no idea what to expect
and I can't I can't congratulate Kenneth
Lori in the league for doing the work
that they did to make those come off as
almost flawlessly as it did we were very
intimidated by the whole cost so not
having a pick there was some comfort in
that again knowing that we already had
that player but just to get the sit back
and watch and know that we couldn't
trade back then we weren't training
future picks we were comfortable in
knowing that that people used on main
care and we still said we should be able
to get six good players so it worked out
perfectly for you then you could take in
the first round as an observer study
what was happening and then that gets
you ready when it's time to get down to
business the next night no question if
the pheno the one thing we sensed like
the trains I don't know I didn't even do
a study on how many were done compared
to previous year that there seemed to be
far less this year especially in the
early rounds people will just say now
look pickin I was fascinated by how
teams would value potential 20 21 draft
picks given this vague possibility that
there won't be college football season
or there will be for some teams not for
others and how much harder that will be
to scout players next year and what the
value of those picks may
were you aware of any discussions
conversations just as to the difficulty
of knowing what a twenty twenty one
draft pick is worth until we know that
there's going to be a college football
season yeah we never got that far down
the world we were just really focused on
2020 2021
that were we're just starting to think
about it now you know we have a combine
meeting virtually in a couple weeks and
we'll start on next year's draft but I
we still didn't think anything about
2021 or we just felt that you know we we
knew we had it those six picks we
weren't interesting and giving up next
year's because we have done some of that
this past year obviously given up picks
to get Bevan Busch in 2019 so we just
wanted to settle and do the best we
could with the six that we hope for the
best
the prospect of scouting for next year
though has to be sewed on and given the
possibility and I think the way it's
going to shake out we will see some
schools play other schools won't play so
if you have a guy who was regarded as a
better player from a school that didn't
play how does that guy get compared to a
lesser prospect who you have 20/20 film
on I mean there's gonna be so many
different ways this can break and so
many different ways you can evaluate
guys guys who play versus guys who don't
play I just feel like next year's draft
is going to be even more of a crapshoot
than a draft usually is it could be and
again we were faced with that this year
coming out you know fortunately we did
get the combine in we didn't get the pro
days and except for a few in the very
beginning and we didn't get to each
other physical that we usually do so we
went into and I think the numbers were
even have 40s on 74 people and we didn't
have physicals on 76 and we just had to
make the most of it when we tried to do
that under the circumstances so that we
move into next year we have a whole Bank
of film 2020 and 2019 at certain schools
don't have the fortune of playing maybe
we have to make some of those decisions
so it is what it is we have to adjust
because again it's not unique to our
store it's not
to our team it's not notes unique to the
world and it's just something while
triangle justice there is a report from
just about four weeks ago that in
pre-draft conversations among general
managers and other executives you had
suggested the possibility of adding
three rounds to the 2020 draft was that
an accurate report and if so what was
the basis for suggesting the possibility
of three more rounds yeah you know what
was this a point about them like that
you know you have what are supposed to
be confidential conference calls when
you discuss ideas about the draft and I
did I did make that suggestion when we
think about three extra rounds and the
reasoning was part of it was selfish you
know you wanted to have a safety net
because we're dealing with less
information and we'll fix you have maybe
we have you have a little a little bit
of a safety net again but the other
thing was it would give the young player
the marginal player who didn't get his
opportunity to go to a pro name that
performed on that opportunity you know
maybe there will be more players drafted
and then again I had the chance that
they might not get the one thing that
we're really missing you know is the
opportunity to try out because there's
no working mini case that's 25 to third
and 12 13 on a given weekend and you
know last year that's where Devlin I
just came from in the past we had Chris
Mingo who came being signed with us when
he signed with Green Bay off of one of
our tryouts
he was Terrence Carter and a linebacker
so every year a team might stumble upon
a tryout player and you know those those
players aren't having that so maybe if
we haven't get run a fool if you think
of a way to help those because there's a
big group of players you don't get
opportunities have you got a situation
have you gotten any indication at all
Kevin is till when teams will be able to
get onto the field when facilities will
be open any sort of a timeline no
everything is still up in the air
when we have is another getting a leg
announced that they will announce the
schedule and it may be something after
that but I'm sure they're they're
working with local governments and I'm
also sure that if it's not good for 32
it's not going to be good for anybody
well and regardless of how many draft
picks a team has how many rounds
ultimately in a draft these young guys
are really gonna be behind the 8-ball
when training camp opens to try to get
the coaches attention to earn a roster
spot so I mean I feel now the veterans
may have no problem with that because
they have to worry about losing their
job to some lowly drafted player who's
gonna have a much tougher climb from 90
to 53 but how do you envision this year
being different from the standpoint of
difficulties in evaluating whether or
not these younger players deserve a spot
on the fun or Oscar yeah it will be
harder we told all of them as we did you
know the video interviews that we could
do and the visit we told them oh look do
what you can focus in on your safety on
your family safety football is always
going to be secondary to that and don't
feel that you're missing anything
because you're not because you you know
you compared to another rookie you're
all in the same boat get to your cities
at the same time and even the veterans
they will still be behind as well
because you know they're not doing what
they usually do so we just emphasize to
the players don't worry don't panic
because we're all going to start
whenever and you all be on equal footing
again they may have a shorter window to
try to prove themselves but it's no
different for one player versus another
so let's have to do the best they can
you've been modest about this in the
past and I respect that very much but
you have developed an incredible ability
at finding receivers in the draft more
often than not guys who come in the mid
to late rounds this year chase Claypool
from Notre Dame sitting there at number
49 in round 2 what is it that attracted
you to him in that spot well chase you
know
again geez we've been watching chase for
two seasons because there's a junior you
know there was a chance that maybe he
come out early and there was some talk
about that he decided to stay so we had
he we are to believe three reports one
of us in junior we got more reports this
year same thing he had improved so we
had a good grades going into the Senior
Bowl when we got down to the Senior Bowl
and coach Tomlin and I got up close on
the practice field and watched his
physicality in blocking drills his
physicality and special teams drills it
really stood out plus he's a 6-4 you
know 230 pound receiver that can get
deep and quite honestly we didn't have
that that threat at least you didn't
have that tall receiver that's receiver
could just thought when covered and
we've always had that in the past with a
Nate Washington and Mike Wallace or
martavis Bryant so again that was very
attractive to us in a long time in the
short term we know chase will be a
special teams contributor right out of
the gate and to have him there at pick
49 how surprised were you by the fact
that he continued to linger and linger I
know there were a lot of receivers this
year which contributed to it but were
you getting nervous that somebody was
going to jump up and snag this guy
before he could land in your lap at 49
not really because again it was a number
of really good receivers and some teams
valued one over another they wanted the
smaller guy they wanted a return capable
bomb there it was really a strongly we
knew that from the beginning so if a
player like chase was there for us great
we would make that pick but there was
options you know we never go into it
locked in on a guy because we have to
sometimes we have to take the best
available and if that player is that one
that you really have locked in on great
it's not there have been other players
who have been certainly able to help our
team
you added running back Anthony McFarland
jr. from Maryland to a depth chart that
has plenty of names and no clearer work
quartz-like levy on Bell once was what
do you envision for the running back
position do you see a revolving door do
you see going with
hot hand or do you hope that one of
these guys will will emerge as the guy
like lady on bail once was you know last
year they were committee and it wasn't a
committee by choice it was a committee
by circumstance because our starter
James Conner was injured and you know
James had an unfortunate misfortunate
year that he suffered acute injuries it
wasn't like it was one injury lingering
week to week or another and they were
real and it was frustrating for James it
was frustrating for us because previous
year when he was healthy he was a pro
bull runner and he's still a young
runner and what we do know is James will
come in whenever we get back on the
field he'll come in healthy he'll be
prepared he'll be ready to go as he
always is and we have some comfort in
that of course we all have to worry
about injury but that's with any plan or
any position so the group itself was
trying to come together under the
circumstances and quite honestly when we
were down to you take a you know future
Hall of Fame quarterback off the field
the offensive production diminishes you
mentioned our ability to to find some
receivers and we've been fortunate in
that regard but they've also played with
quarterback and I think that makes the
whole offense better so with a guy like
Anthony mcFarland yeah has a little
different dimension than maybe some of
the other guys we have we have another
fast guy and careth way who helps us
with the kick returns but Anthony just
gives you a little changeup out of the
bathroom you know people say small but
he's 200 he played plays about 203 and
he can run and he's got really good
short hair and quickness and when he
finds a crease he can finish as he's
proven so he didn't had a great year
last year it's probably why he was
available in the fourth round because of
an ankle injury but it was pretty easy
to pick at that point because he should
be able to complement the other guys I
don't know how much noise makes its way
through the team's bubble but there has
been plenty of talk this offseason about
veteran quarterbacks to serve as the
number two behind Ben Roethlisberger it
was Jameis Winston more recently Andy
Dalton it's been one guy after another
where do you stand on the possibility of
adding of veteran versus sticking with
the the depth chart that you have with
mason rudolph duck Hodges and Paxton
Lynch you know again when you look back
over the history of bed when Ben was
young and ascending we had veteran
quarterbacks behind him when he became
that veteran we've always had a younger
younger drafted Clair in behind him and
that's by design because you're always
trying to develop guys as you know has
been moves into a later stage of his
career and maybe get the next one you
know that you know Andy combs developed
into a nice backup Josh what dogs did
and now you know Mason did last year and
we're comfortable with Mason move off as
a backup and Devlin Hodges in the mix
you know between the two of them they
were eight and six last year in and
backup quarterback situation you know
eight and six it's not 14 and old but
there's some comfort in knowing that
they can get you through the hopefully
non-existent spell that may occur if
your quarterback gets injured so a lot
of times when you know you're getting
the salary camp being a Dominion you
have you know significant dollars in
your starter it's hard to put a lot of
dollars at you back up and we're very
comfortable knowing it if me being Mason
and Devlin and or Devlin or Mason even a
Paxton mention who's got super you know
number one talent you mentioned the
scheduled earlier Kevin and look I know
that every team will have its
preferences maybe some requests from
time to time of the league what is it
you're hoping to see when they pull the
sheet off of the 256 games late on
Thursday night well I have no idea
because it is what it is we have no
input other than say we prefer to you
know open at home or way I think every
team can do that I'm not involved with
that and I really whatever they give us
we tried we have to make the most of it
you know and this year will be different
because of the unknowns and nobody
no and I really don't have a preference
because we can't we can't influence it
one way or another so it's just our job
to make the most of it when it comes out
now that we've gotten through the draft
and they've been undrafted free agent
sign and the dust is starting to settle
what is your life like what is it that
you're doing differently than what you
would be doing in a normal year well you
know the difference is we would be
preparing for a working mini camp and
making sure we had the tryout fighters
lined up to get us to that camp because
usually only had about 18 to 20 players
on your roster that you qualify so again
nice to have 2530 tryouts you have to
get lined up and ready for this camp
obviously we're not doing that so we
always go back and we do some different
Studies on where we had guys graded
where they got picked and so on and so
forth and like I said we're moving into
the preparation for the 2021 draft with
our Blessed ou combine meeting which
will actually on May 18th it's amazing
even when it stops it never stops
there's always something to do and we
appreciate you giving us some of your
time because I know you're busy all year
round and we enjoy watching what you're
doing and putting this team together for
2020 but wish you all the best Kevin
look forward to talking to you again
soon all right Mikey take care now
Thanks Thank You papa
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports